[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOT PANSING: Our guest today
is William Knoedelseder.
Full disclosure, he's
a friend of mine.
So going to be calling
him Bill, William,
a little interchangeably.
Bill worked at the LA
Times from 1977 to 1989,
where he was part of the
whole music industry payola
situation, helped
to blow that up.
And that resulted in his book,
"Stiffed: A True Story of MCA,
the Music Business,
and the Mafia."
His latest book is called
"Bitter Brew: The Rise and Fall
of Anheuser-Busch and
America's Kings of Beer,"
of which he has already been
to Google to speak about.
You may remember that.
And that is on the
YouTube channel.
In 2010, "I'm Dying Up Here:
Heartbreak and High Times
in Stand-Up Comedy's
Golden Era,"
was released, which is
now a Showtime show.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So without further ado,
please welcome back
to Google William Knoedelseder.
[APPLAUSE]
The book, I have to say,
Bill, is an amazing document
of the rebirth
and transformation
of American stand-up comedy.
So again, thank
you for being here.
I feel like it's kind
of an "On the Road,"
or maybe "Electric Kool-Aid
Acid Test" for comedians,
or at least people interested
in stand-up comedy.
But I'm going to throw you
a real softball here first.
But it's an important softball.
Bill, what is the
biggest difference
between your book and the
show, "I'm Dying Up Here?"
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Mine is true.
And theirs is fictionalized,
based on the real events.
But they didn't do
the real characters.
And there's a reason for that.
And I wasn't surprised.
And I was supportive of that.
The story in the book
basically takes place
in about a year
and a half's time.
And it involves all these
real life guys, and women,
mostly guys, who went on to
considerable fame and fortune.
But the TV series,
they want the TV series
to be on for five years.
And so do I.
They had to be able to
have the creative license
to make up things.
And they didn't want to
have things coming out
of David Letterman's
mouth at age 27
that David Letterman didn't say.
So to keep it tightly to the
story in the book limited
the ability to have five
years' worth of material.
So that's what they do.
That's a normal
thing in Hollywood.
So that would be
the big difference.
You're not going to see David
Letterman or Leno or any
of the guys and gals
who are in the book.
SCOT PANSING: We see
some, like Johnny Carson,
or certain people are--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Carson, he's the only person.
Richard Pryor, they have
a Richard Pryor in there.
SCOT PANSING: And the "Let's
Make a Deal" host, Monty Hall.
He's real, though.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Yes, I know.
But I could sit there
and see all myriad things
that they got from the
book that so-and-so said,
but they're coming out of
this character's mouth.
And it happened this
way in the book,
but they've changed it to this.
And the world that they create,
and the relationships they
create are all accurate.
I mean, they're all from
that world, in that time.
SCOT PANSING: Yeah, it
seemed like they sort of--
I noticed that some things that
were maybe the same character,
they would take those
anecdotes and spread them
among two separate characters.
Or this character, this happened
to him and now this other thing
happened to him from another.
But it still all kind of works.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Right.
And their idea going
into this, and I
knew this from the outset,
was that they wanted to-- this
was Jim Carrey's
idea, that he went
through this same
system of club comics
out here, the same place.
He went through about 10 years
after the events in the book.
And he was fascinated
by doing a TV series
about the dark side of comedy.
And there is
definitely a dark side
to these people who get
up on a stage like this
with a microphone
and they try and get
that audience to love them.
And they bring a lot of
baggage to the stage.
There's a reason that they
were compelled to do that.
So that all comes out.
So their idea was
that it was going
to be the dark side of comedy.
That was the way they'd
sold it to the network.
So it's a little
darker than in my book.
But that's fine.
I mean, when the book--
when the real events
took place, 30 years ago,
you didn't see comics
everywhere all the time.
Comics weren't ubiquitous.
Matter of fact, the only place
you saw comics in America
is you saw them on
the Ed Sullivan Show,
or you saw them on the
Johnny Carson Tonight Show.
That was it.
And if they didn't
get on those shows,
they didn't have a career.
And if you wanted
to see a comic live,
you had to go to two clubs.
One was in New York
and one was here.
And there were no videotapes
that were being sent around.
There was no channel to watch
comics on, wall to wall.
So it was a much
smaller profession.
And they were young
and desperate to get
in front of some sort of media
so they would have a career
and they could make
money being funny.
And it wasn't as easy--
not that it's easy now.
But there's
certainly much more--
SCOT PANSING: A
few more avenues.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: --outlets
than there was back then.
SCOT PANSING: They
definitely captured, I think,
in the show, the sort of
control that Goldy or Mitzi--
Goldy's a real person
in the show, too,
although the name's
just changed, right?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Exactly.
SCOT PANSING: But where she
doesn't even pay them at first,
and she's like, look,
this is access to Carson.
And that's what
you're getting here.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
That's how it worked.
What happened was, the
history of this was--
and my role then, I
was a junior reporter
at the Los Angeles Times.
And my editor called me in
one day and said, you know,
there's something going on
here with these young comics
here in town that feels like
Greenwich Village in the 1960s.
And would you like to
cover the comedy beat?
So he decided that we
would have a comedy beat,
when I was the exact same
age as all these people.
And I thought,
there's going to be
a comedy beat for
the LA Times, and I'm
going to get to cover it?
And so it was like
the dream job,
because they were all 26 or 27.
And what happened was in '73
or '74, the Carson Show, which
was the only place
you could see comics,
he decided he wanted
to live in California.
He didn't like New York.
So he moved the show to Burbank.
And what happened was that all
the comics lived in New York,
because you had to be someplace
where the talent scouts
for the Tonight Show walked into
the club and saw you and said,
yeah, you can be on the show.
Well, you could hear the
suitcases of all the class
clowns packing.
The minute he moved out
here, they literally-- there
was this invisible
immigration of class clowns
that just within a couple years,
packed up, left home, and came
out to-- and moved into
crappy little apartments
in West Hollywood.
And they formed this
sort of community.
And I got the amazing job
of, OK, you cover that.
Find out what's going
on with those people,
because it's a really
unusual art form.
Who's happening?
Who's funny?
What's different
about them that's
different from the other guys,
the Bill Cosbys and the Bob
Newharts?
So what's different
about these people?
And who's going to
happen next and all that?
That was my job.
And I got to sit there,
right there in the front row,
as all these people
walked up on the stage,
sometimes for the first time,
and tried to make people laugh.
And it was the best
gig I ever had.
SCOT PANSING: Sounds
pretty awesome.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
So yeah, it was great.
So 30 years later, here you
are, still talking about it.
Because at the time, my
editor, who was my mentor--
he's passed on now--
he had a sense that there were
something meaningful going on.
And it was.
There was something really
meaningful going on.
And I didn't realize
it at the time,
because I was fresh from
St. Louis, my first gig.
They were trying out a
whole new kind of comedy
that wasn't just set-ups
and one-liners and the stuff
that you saw Bob Hope do.
Bob Hope never made me laugh
one time in all my life.
I would watch him and I
just never chuckled once.
So these kids were
making up new stuff.
And they were talking about
sex, and their mothers,
and blah blah blah, and it was
all a different kind of humor.
SCOT PANSING: It's that
transition from the suit comic,
like Carlin in a suit
to Carlin in a sweater.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Exactly.
Carlin changed the
thing in mid-sentence.
And Richard Pryor did, too.
I mean, they had both
been the suit comics on--
and they would do the
traditional jokes.
They were doing-- the big guy
was Bill Cosby and Bob Newhart.
It was routines.
And they were funny.
But they didn't relate to
people who were 10, 12, 15
years younger than them.
They didn't.
And the other
thing was is that--
and this comes into
play in the show now,
they did pick up on this--
at the time, in America, young
women weren't class clowns.
I was never in a class where
the girl was the funny one.
It was always the guy.
They weren't given license to
be funny and speak up in class.
And they didn't have
any role models.
With role models they saw, they
would see these older women
who sort of did this
self-deprecating, harried
housewife camera.
And it didn't relate
to them at all.
So they didn't really
want to be comics.
So there wasn't a
wealth of people,
women packing up their bags
and moving to Los Angeles.
At one time, we
calculated that in 1978,
when I started doing this,
there was 300 stand-up comics
in Los Angeles.
Well, that's the most stand-up
comics that at that point
had ever been anywhere.
And probably 20 of them women.
The ratio was that--
the discrepancy was that big.
So it was a guy thing.
And they get that in the show.
That's one of the things
they cover in the show.
SCOT PANSING: The
character Cassie
seems almost like a cross
between like Elayne Boosler
and Sandra Bernhard
or something, at least
with the struggles of
the women back then.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Right, right.
I think it's mostly--
I mean, they-- in
the show, she's
the only woman who's among them.
That would be
Elayne, because she
was the only woman among
the group of guys that
went to Canter's and all that.
That's all fairly
accurate, although she's
not at all like Elayne.
SCOT PANSING: But again, there
are fictional characters.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Yeah, it
doesn't matter to the audience.
They didn't see Elayne.
SCOT PANSING: I thought
they did a really good--
you mentioned all the suitcases
coming across the country.
I think they did
a good job with,
I think the actor's Clark
Duke and his friend.
But the two guys from Boston.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Yeah, but that was--
SCOT PANSING: Sleeping
in the closet.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
You know how it works.
They have these two characters.
And they made them two guys.
They come from Boston.
But all the background
that you see of them
is why they leave Boston and
what they're doing in Boston.
That's Jay Leno.
That's Leno's playing in The
Combat Zone with strippers
on the stage and all that.
They took Leno's
background from the book
and then gave it to
these two characters,
because it served their dramatic
needs more than just one guy,
I guess.
I mean, I wasn't--
I'm not part of the show.
My job was to write the book
and accept money for that
and from them.
And I was happy.
SCOT PANSING: It's a good job.
But what is it like?
Can you take us through
a little bit of--
the book comes out in 2010.
And you mentioned to
me a long time ago
that Jim Carrey had
optioned the rights.
So at least can you tell me
what happens from that point?
What happened--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: You
want the whole 30-year book?
SCOT PANSING: What happens--
no.
What happens when
they option your book?
And what happens from there?
Did you speak to
Jim Carrey at all?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Never.
I've never spoken to him.
SCOT PANSING: I also know that
he played Andy Kaufman in "Man
in the Moon."
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: He did.
SCOT PANSING: And you have
an Andy Kaufman connection.
But you never worked
with him on that movie.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
No, no, no, no, no, no.
The way it worked was
that the book came out--
I can't remember when
the book came out--
and they very quickly
optioned the book.
And optioning a book
means they pay you
so that they can then hold
the rights while they go out
and try and make a deal.
And then nobody else
is trying to sell it.
So they pay you some
amount of money.
It's not usually
very much money.
And I found out-- this was
my first experience going all
the way through the process--
I've since had it happen again--
but this is my first ride--
how long it takes
to get everything
that you need to get together
to get something on television.
Somebody has to be willing to
sign on to be the show runner
and do all this, and maybe
spend the next four or five
years of their life
doing this at the price
that they're being offered.
And the network has to--
and it literally took, I
guess four years for them
to set up a thing at Showtime.
And then it took another year.
So it was all
totaled, six years,
I think, from the time the book
came out to where we are now.
Or maybe more.
SCOT PANSING: Seven, I think.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Seven.
SCOT PANSING:
That's a long time.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Fortunately, I had
other things to do.
And it wasn't my
headache, because I didn't
have to deal with any of it.
They were just off doing it.
And they had to go
hire all these people.
And it's a difficult
thing to do.
They have to hire people who can
write bad comedy intentionally.
Bad comedy in 1970, so
it has to be authentic.
But these are supposedly young
comics doing stuff and bombing
on stage.
Well, someone's
got to write that.
And you've got to be able to
get what they were going after
and why it missed or
it doesn't make sense.
SCOT PANSING: It still
needs to be entertaining.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Well,
I can't imagine doing that.
That's a very hard thing to do.
SCOT PANSING: I'd
like to go back
a little bit to your
time with the LA Times,
and during this era that
is touched on in the book,
but I've only seen
three episodes so far.
I'm not sure if
they bring this in.
But talk to me a little
bit about Andy Kaufman
and how you got to
basically ride shotgun
during his experience
with Tony Clifton.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
As I said, my job
was to go find out who
was the next big person.
I mean, I was there the first
night Robin Williams broke big.
And nobody had ever seen
anything quite like that.
He jumped up on stage and
everybody's mouth just dropped.
And he was up there
doing this stuff.
And it was like, oh my god.
There was no template for that.
And there was no template for
what Andy Kaufman was doing.
And so they were all
coming out and arriving.
Andy came from New Jersey
somewhere, Colts Neck or White
Plains or something like that.
He came out of nowhere.
And he was just bizarre.
He didn't really--
he did it on a stage,
but he wasn't a
stand-up comedian.
He did performance art.
And so I wanted to--
he had a character who
was an alter ego of his
that he had never admitted
was his character.
And his name was Tony Clifton.
And he was this terrible,
abusive lounge singer.
And Andy portrayed him.
He would go on stage,
but he would always
deny that that was him.
It takes a kind of personality
to make that work with everyone
and never break character,
even though you all
know it's really him.
He would never admit it.
And when he was on
the show "Taxi,"
he convinced the executive
producer of a hit network
show to hire Tony
Clifton in a role.
And you understand, it's not me.
I just know Tony.
He's telling these Hollywood
producers in the studio.
So they think this
might be a funny bit.
So they hire Tony.
And Andy was a vitamin
gulping, vegan, nonsmoking guy.
And Tony was-- as Tony, he was
a whore-mongering, drunken,
porno-consuming asshole.
So they hired Tony.
And of course, Andy
was off that week.
And they hired Tony.
And he was going to portray
a character on the show
with the rest of the cast.
Now the rest of the cast
wasn't OK with this,
because Tony was an asshole.
And he had a
trailer out in back.
And he drank all day.
And he had hookers
in the trailer.
And he was abusive
to all the women,
because that was the character.
So it was really untenable.
And they decided--
they couldn't talk
to Andy, because Andy wouldn't
admit that he was Tony.
So they had to fire Tony.
These are executive
producers of a major hit show
down at Paramount,
on the Paramount lot,
who are going, what we do?
OK, we'll fire Tony.
We'll just let him go.
And Andy's cast, they
were furious at this guy,
because he screwed
up everything.
And so of course, Andy's
got something going on here.
He tells his manager to call
up the guy from the LA Times,
because I was the LA Times
guy who covered comics.
And they wanted to get
in front of me really
badly, because I'd
write about them
and they'd be in the LA Times.
So I was important.
So they invited me.
They said something's going
to happen on the set today.
And they made sure
that I was there.
And I didn't know what it was.
But I was doing a story.
I was in the middle
doing a story on Andy.
I went down and I had my camera.
And I was sitting
there in the stands
as this whole thing unfolds.
Tony comes.
He comes onto the set where
they're all getting ready.
And the other players are
all there glowering at him.
And he's got these two hookers.
And he's reeking of booze.
But he's got presents
for the whole staff.
And he's handing them out.
And the executive producers
tell him he's fired.
Andy, I'm saying.
It's not Andy.
It's Tony.
I forgot.
They fire him and he goes crazy.
And they have to call
in the security guards.
He starts fighting them.
And I'm sitting
there with my camera.
So I just start taking
pictures of this.
And they struggle.
They get him out in the alley.
And I'm out in the
alley taking pictures.
And then the security guards
set upon me and grab my camera
and take my camera.
I mean, this is--
and they haul Tony,
and they literally
throw him off the lot.
And I'm sitting there
without my camera.
And I'm on assignment
for the LA Times
and they've
confiscated my camera.
I get it back.
And that was it.
I mean, that's how they
got rid of Tony Clifton.
But the pictures that I took
still are on the internet.
And they're famous now.
I get a call once
or twice a year.
Somebody realizes that I own
the rights to that picture.
Can they buy the
rights to reprint
the picture, a famous picture of
Andy Kaufman, as Tony Clifton,
being thrown off the
lot at Paramount?
But it was bizarre.
And then what happened was
after that they called me--
somehow Andy's people got my
camera back from the guards--
and they said that Tony
would like to meet me
that night, just the two of us.
And I said, that's fine.
OK, I said, we'll do that.
So I met Tony at this bar on--
I think it was on Hollywood
Boulevard, some sleazy bar.
Oh no, I met him at a motel
on Sunset, a hooker motel.
Oh my god.
And we went for a drink
across the street.
It's a place that I picked.
And he started hitting
on the owner's daughter.
This guy, who was
going to kill us.
But Andy would not break
his character at all.
He wouldn't.
He just stayed with
the guy, with Tony.
And I finally had
to leave, because I
thought that we were going
to get in really bad trouble.
And that was fine.
I was a journalist.
But I don't have to go to jail
with him to get the story.
You go ahead.
That was it.
So I wrote that story up.
And then, of course,
some of that, I guess,
ended up in the book years
later with Jim Carrey.
SCOT PANSING: I mean,
didn't he perform--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
He was very good.
SCOT PANSING: --for you
at your house, as well?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
[INAUDIBLE] while I was
preparing, before this
evening happened--
so I knew Andy was odd, I
was going to interview him
for this profile.
I was going to do the
first big major newspaper
profile on this guy
named Andy Kaufman,
the world really
didn't know about.
They knew something
about him, but not much.
He had just appeared
on this TV show.
So he was a guy on a TV
show, but nobody really
knew what he was other
than that weird character.
So I was going to interview him.
And a couple of nights
before that was to happen,
days, a couple days before,
I get a call at 7:00
at night, 8:00, whatever, and
he says, hi, this is Andy,
can I come over?
And I thought, to my house?
Yeah, OK.
I said, well, yeah, OK.
So he shows up a
half an hour later.
He comes walking into my
house, this crazy comic,
with a suitcase full of--
like an old vaudeville
suitcase full of clothes.
And he proceeded to do
his whole act in pantomime
out on my patio.
And then he would go
change into another outfit
and then come back
out and do the whole--
Oh, yes-- oh, yeah.
I'm waving this around.
And I'm supposed to
be talking into it.
Imagine that.
So anyway, that was
another bizarre thing.
And then he left.
So I became sort of the
resident world expert
on Andy Kaufman for years.
And the weird thing
is that I have
a son who's 25 who has a picture
from that night where he-- oh,
the rest of the night that he
was on my patio, he had it,
he changed into his
wrestling outfit.
And he wanted to
wrestle my wife, who
was then eight months pregnant.
And I have a picture of him.
And she was like five
feet tall and pregnant.
And he wanted to wrestle her.
So the pictures
from that night are
on my son's wall in his room.
And every time one of his new
friend comes in, they go, whoa,
you got a picture
of Andy Kaufman.
I wouldn't have imagined
that anyone 25 would
know who Andy Kaufman is.
No, they all know
who Andy Kaufman is.
And they cannot believe that
Colin's dad actually knew Andy
Kaufman and actually had
an encounter with him,
because he's that legendary.
SCOT PANSING: Well, no one
believed him when he got sick.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Exactly.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
It's crazy.
People still think
he's still alive.
So anyway, but I'll hold it.
SCOT PANSING: Thanks for
sharing that part with me.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: That's
one of my brushes with fame.
SCOT PANSING: I think I even saw
on maybe Don Cheadle's Twitter
or something where it's a
caricature of Donald Trump,
but he's pulling off a costume,
and it's actually Andy Kaufman.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Yeah, it's Andy Kaufman.
No, he definitely did die.
The weird thing was he died
of some kind of lung cancer
or something like that,
and he didn't smoke.
Didn't drink, and
had vitamins lined up
in his kitchen for miles.
So just goes to show
you, be careful.
SCOT PANSING: For sure.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I think
it was vitamins that killed him.
SCOT PANSING: Too many vitamins?
Maybe.
You talked about Robin Williams,
seeing him before he blew up,
before "Mork and Mindy."
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: It
was right at that time.
He wasn't really imprinted.
I think it was like a week
or two before that hit,
but he was just
like a normal guy.
And then it became huge,
because if you think about it,
the way things are
now, "Mork and Mindy"
was the TV show that he went on.
He was unknown.
"Mork and Mindy" was
watched every week
by 57 million people.
That's the kind of audience.
A hit show now, you
have 10 million people.
They got 57 million people.
So he became so famous, so fast.
It wasn't like he got recognized
when he went out on the street.
He would get mobbed
out on the street.
And two months before, he'd
just been some comic working
at The Comedy Store for free.
SCOT PANSING: And
Richard Lewis also
had a big part in the book.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Richard Lewis.
SCOT PANSING: And
you're friends with him.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I got
to know Richard pretty well.
I got to know some of them.
They were different.
I was a journalist, and
they were the performers.
So there was a--
SCOT PANSING: His story is
pretty central in the book,
though, with his friend
Steve and whatnot.
And I see them working parts
of that also into the show,
but in different ways.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Yeah,
that was a story line.
The thing about the book,
the way it happened was I
did all this, I covered
this whole thing
for a couple of years.
And then there was an event
that happened in mid-1979.
It was a tragedy occurred to
one of this group of people.
And it was really upsetting.
But it was an amazing story.
And after that was
done, I'd been doing it
for a year and a half.
And I literally
asked my editor--
I said, I feel like
I'm done with this.
I feel like I'd rather
move on to another--
because it was getting kind
of heavy, because it was real.
They were trying
really, really hard.
And a lot of them
were living in cars.
And they were broke.
And it was a very
emotional thing.
And I was seeing
the dark side of it.
They were so desperate.
And there was a
lot of-- and they
would call me in the middle
of the night and want to talk.
And they were very funny.
But there was a sad side of it.
So I asked off the comedy beat.
I was probably put on
the organized crime
beat, which was a relief.
Oh, they have so
many less problems.
They're just brutal.
They're direct about it.
They're brutal.
That's all right.
But then what happened
was-- but that story,
the story about what happened
was a big story that people
remember years later.
And I'd have
somebody mention it,
because we did a
really big long form
article in the
calendar section, which
had never been done before.
And I always remembered it
as a big thing in my career,
because it kicked off
my narrative career.
And then one day, about
27 years after all that
happened, I was
reading the paper
and I saw an obit of a
comedian named George--
SCOT PANSING: George Miller?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Yeah.
George Miller,
yeah, George Miller.
See, you forget a name like--
SCOT PANSING: That's
why I'm here, Bill.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: You
forget a name like Miller.
It's forgettable.
And George had died.
And I remember George, because
he'd been a source of mine
back when all this
stuff was happening.
And he was a great guy.
And it said that he'd been--
and I knew George
back at the time.
He was David
Letterman's best friend.
And they lived right
across the street
from The Comedy
Store and all that.
And the article
said that they were
having a public memorial
for him at The Laugh
Factory on Sunset on Sunday.
So I thought, wow, you know
what, I'm going to go to that.
Because I haven't seen
those guys in years.
And we were all the same age.
We were all 26, 27 years old.
So years later,
one of them died.
And I thought that maybe
they'll all come back.
It'll be like a
Big Chill moment.
And so I went over there
on a Sunday afternoon.
And sure enough, they all did.
All of a sudden, all these
people came walking back in.
Richard, and the
only one who didn't--
Leno, and now we're all 50, and
a little thicker and gray hair.
But to a person,
when they got up
to talk about George,
this guy that they
had known for all these
years, every one of them,
their reference point
was this four-year period
between 1975 and '79,
when they were all
working at The Comedy Store.
Some of them in the room had
gone on to lead huge lives
and make millions
of dollars and were
recognized wherever they go.
But the time of their
life that they remember
were these four years when
they were working on this strip
here with this crazy little
woman who owned the club, who
had dominion over their lives,
and they were making no money
and they were struggling.
Looking back, that's when
they became who they are.
That's what they think.
And they all talked
about that four years.
All their memories were settled.
And I left there that afternoon
and thought, wow, boy, there's
a really great book in this.
Because looking
back on that now,
as they do, middle-aged
people, through the rosy glow
of memory, they have a
much better perspective
on what happened back then.
Back then, they were all
just going through it.
Now they had-- so I literally
sold the book like that
to my publisher.
And everybody who I talked to
at 27, I was talking to at 55.
And it was a great story.
SCOT PANSING: And you were
able to go back and talk
to many of them.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: So I
mean, the whole thing was--
I researched the book
for 30 years, basically.
And then it all sort
of came together.
And it was fairly easy to
write, because I knew--
and I still had notes from
27-year-old Richard Lewis,
from an interview I did back
on my back porch in 1979,
because I kept all that stuff.
So it was a great experience
being able to do that.
SCOT PANSING: One
other name I just
want to mention before we
get a little more current
is someone I wasn't too
familiar with until I
read the book was Tom Dreesden?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Tom Dreesen, yeah.
SCOT PANSING: And
he sort of became
the rep of the younger guys.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Well, he's
sort of the hero of the book.
Tom was a comic who was a few
years older than most of them.
He'd come from a very poor
background, where a lot of them
were upper middle class
kids, went to college
and they were all college
graduates and all that stuff.
So Tom was three or
four years older.
And he'd grown up really poor
and kind of worked his way up.
And he was married
and had a family.
And even though they were
27 and Tom was 32, 33.
So he was like a father
figure to a lot of them.
He was making
money and all that.
So what happened--
I have to talk about the strike.
What happened is after
a couple of years
of working for Mitzi
Shore at The Comedy Store,
and she didn't pay them.
The idea was, no,
this is not-- this
is not a place to get paid.
I'll give you my stage and
you get hired in the business.
So you work for me for free.
And that's one of the things
that's in the TV series
that they build on.
And they were willing to do
that, because that was true.
If you got on the stage
at The Comedy Store,
like Freddie Prinze
did one night,
the next week he had a TV series
and he was rich and famous.
So that's what they
were all doing.
So she didn't pay them.
But as 300 people converged
on town, not all of them
got famous.
And the rest of them were
out here working for nothing.
And they were desperate.
And they were eating
out of dumpsters
and living in their cars
and selling this and doing--
and it got kind of--
And actually, it was Leno
who sort of broached the idea
one night.
They had just all been
played on a New Year's
Eve at the main room.
And there had been
all these people.
And Mitzi had made
all this money.
And he said, shouldn't
we get paid for this?
It took four of us to pack
the room, but we packed it.
And so he started talking--
and he didn't need the money.
He was making money.
So what they did was they
formed a quasi-union.
And the leader of it, the
guy who was the oldest
guy, who they--
Tom, you tell them--
Tom Dreesen, he became
he became a spokesman
and he became the leader of the
insurgency that went to Mitzi
and asked for--
can you pay us?
Can you pay us $5 a set?
And nope, she refused to do it.
And she kept refusing,
kept refusing.
And then finally, they realized
that the only thing they could
do-- they could keep
asking and getting refused,
or they could throw a picket
line around that place
and go on strike.
So that's what she did.
And for me as a reporter,
I'd been covering these guys
as artists and comedians.
And it was all fun and
games and all of that.
And all of a sudden
there was a story
that comedians are going on
strike at The Comedy Store.
They have picket lines.
And it was kind of
funny, a funny idea.
So I went over to cover it.
And all the networks were there.
And they all covered
it for a day or two.
And then they went on,
because they covered it
for the goof of it.
The comics are down there.
They're picketing.
And then they moved on.
But they still
had the situation.
And they had all risked
their careers by doing this.
Because she was going to
punish them, they figured.
And that's when the incident
occurred that I won't tell you
about, because I don't--
SCOT PANSING: Yeah,
don't ruin the book.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
I mean, I don't know
if you're going to read it.
But if you do read it, you'll
be happy that I didn't tell you.
And Dreesen, it's his legacy.
And he did something.
And now when Tom, he
tells me all the time,
because of the
book, he'll be out--
Tom works all the
time-- and he'll be out,
and some young comics will
come up with him and say,
you know, man, I got
paid the first time
I walked on stage,
thanks to you,
because you went on
strike back then.
And you got us paid.
I don't get paid a lot.
They actually get paid
less now than they
got paid after the strike.
But they get paid.
So Tom's this guy that
they all appreciate.
SCOT PANSING: Sort of
set up the structure
for the '80s, where in Ohio,
there's Ha Has and Laugh-In.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Right after the strike
is when the whole comedy
thing broke wide open.
And all of a sudden,
there was comedy channels
and there was syndicated
shows, improv this.
And they got paid.
If they hadn't done this, had
this incident not happened
and this strike taken place
in the spring of 1979,
maybe it would have
happened at some point.
Somebody would have
done something.
But this is what
caused it to happen.
Because they shut down The
Comedy Store on Sunset Strip.
They shut it down for weeks.
And they made it so that
she could not operate.
And they forced her
to negotiate with them
and begin paying them
for their services.
I mean, she was paying
everybody else who
worked in the club,
the people who
cleaned the toilets,
the waiters, everybody.
But she wasn't
paying the people who
were bringing in the crowds.
And she literally,
legitimately--
in her mind, anyway--
her feeling was, no, this is--
and there was some truth
to what she was saying.
She just wouldn't
see their side,
that she was making a lot of
money and driving a nice car
and they were getting nothing.
But the minute the
strike was over,
the union went
away, because comics
and a union don't go together.
They're not really--
SCOT PANSING: But it did set
the stage, really, for the '80s.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Oh, totally.
SCOT PANSING: And I
know you don't really
say you like a lot of current
comedy or stand-up comics
very much, I know.
But do you have--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Oh, I do, but I just
don't want to pick them out.
But I can tell
you who I do like.
SCOT PANSING: Who do you like?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I
think Louis C.K.'s brilliant.
SCOT PANSING: Louis C.K.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Jim Jeffries.
There's a lot of
them I don't know.
Who do I think of that I like?
SCOT PANSING: Do
you like Bill Burr?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
I like Bill Burr.
I know who he is.
At least I know who he is.
Amy Schumer, of
course, is great.
She can be pretty raw at times.
Sarah Silverman I love.
SCOT PANSING: Do you go down
to the clubs ever still at all?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I
do every now and then.
It's the only place I'm famous.
SCOT PANSING: You
wrote the book on it.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
I think 2/3
of the copies of "I'm Dying"
ever sold were sold to comics.
They all have a copy.
And so if I go into a club,
it's like, oh, that's the guy.
And they'll want to meet me.
It's funny.
It's a very small world.
But it's good to be famous in
some little controllable group,
I guess.
So I enjoy going to comics.
It's still very hard for me,
like it is hard for anyone
to watch a comic who's bombing.
SCOT PANSING: It's
very uncomfortable.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I can't
bear it, because I feel bad.
And then every now and
then, like recently,
I happened to be at The Improv,
meeting a friend for something.
And because someone said,
oh, that's the guy that wrote
"I'm Dying Up Here,"
we got escorted
into the back room of The
Improv and seated at a table.
And out walks Dave Chapelle
and does an hour off
the top of his head.
Hysterical.
I mean, just hysterical.
We were like slack jawed.
I'd never seen
Dave Chapelle live.
And he's just brilliant.
I mean, he was as good that
night as I ever saw Pryor.
I mean, and if you talk about
who do I think-- for me?
SCOT PANSING: Top of all time.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
For me, Richard Pryor.
He was the van Gogh
of stand-up comedy.
There's never been
anybody better.
There's van Gogh and
Pryor and all the rest
of them, which is not to say I
didn't like George Carlin, who
I knew.
But Richard Pryor set
the bar real high.
And I think that if you really
did a poll, majority of them
would come out that Richard
Pryor was the greatest
stand-up of the last
50, 60 years, anyway.
SCOT PANSING: Sort of the
accepted, critically acclaimed.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Yeah, I would think.
I could be wrong.
There could be all
kinds of young people
say I don't know anything,
and they might be right.
But I don't know.
There's so many comics now.
You can't keep up with it.
Back then, there were not that
many to have to know about.
Now there's hundreds.
SCOT PANSING: Well, they
have so many channels, too.
They can go on at
midnight on a game show.
They have a lot of stuff to do.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
There are people
I find out who are
doing very well
and have very big careers
who I've never heard of.
And I stay up on pop culture.
That's always been my business.
And so it's hard to keep up.
SCOT PANSING: Well, Bill,
thank you for talking with us.
I want to open it
to a little audience
Q&A. Adam has this cool
new furry microphone
that if you raise your hand,
he will throw it to you.
You catch it.
And you can speak
into the blue box.
Does anyone want to
catch the microphone?
Come on, please.
There we go.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
And I have a question
about that in a minute,
Adam, when we're done here.
The thinking behind throwing
something that's a box shape.
SCOT PANSING: But it's
like a stuffed animal.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
I understand.
But like, round.
SCOT PANSING: It could be round.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
You know what I mean?
I would think you'd
make it round.
But OK.
SCOT PANSING: Good feedback.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I digress.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I really enjoyed your
story about Andy Kaufman
and the sidebar with
Tony Clifton, of course.
Tony Clifton's still around
and you still see the act.
Most recently, just
this year alone--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
How did that happen?
AUDIENCE: How does this happen?
Sort of where my
question's going.
So he was on Jeff Ross Crowd
Control within the last year.
I think that's on Seeso.
And he was at House of Blues
something like a decade
ago here in Los Angeles.
Have you seen any of those acts?
How would you think it compares?
And who is that?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Well, I know who that is.
SCOT PANSING: I think I do, too.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
And I can guarantee you
that it's not Andy Kaufman.
But it's somebody who was
with Andy the whole way who
portrays that character.
And I don't know if I
should say the name.
But I know who it is.
And it keeps the
legend of Andy alive.
And they still play with the
idea that Andy still is alive.
Maybe he is.
It's like Elvis impersonators.
It's all a tribute to Andy.
And he does it out of love.
And he makes money doing it.
And I don't know if
the joke works anymore.
I mean, I guess the people
who know Andy Kaufman know
who Tony Clifton is.
I mean, Andy's popularity
was inexplicable then--
and I'm not saying that
he wasn't talented,
because he did a
thing that nobody did.
And he was absolutely
dedicated to it.
You could not get Andy to
break character no matter what.
You could have threatened
to shoot his children
and he wouldn't have
broken character.
He was that dedicated to it.
There's something about it.
It's still alive.
My kids are in awe that
I knew Andy Kaufman.
I knew all kinds of
more famous people,
but Andy Kaufman matters.
The others don't.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SCOT PANSING: Thank
you for the question.
Follow-up or no?
Or do you wanna throw the box?
AUDIENCE: Well, just that on the
Jeff Ross show, he was booed.
If anything, the crowd
was mostly silent.
And this was a show
where the whole point was
to ratchet up the irritation
of the audience as much
as possible.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And Tony
Clifton continues
to go as far over
that line as possible.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: But you
understand, to the Tony Clifton
character, who's ever in the
costume, that's applause.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
They're not there
to get anyone's,
isn't this great?
They're there to make everybody
as uncomfortable as possible
and get them all upset
and then realize later
that boy, that was really weird
what we just participated in.
That's what it is.
It's an odd kind
of entertainment.
But it's still-- awful
lot of really good comics
are not working anymore.
But Tony Clifton's still
making appearances.
Anyone else?
SCOT PANSING: Anyone
else for the blue cube?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Throw a box?
SCOT PANSING: In the back.
Nice catch.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So there's a Mitch
Hedberg joke about something
you were talking about,
which is that the success
path for comedy is that
you're good at stand-up
and then people
with money show up
and ask you to do other things,
like write a book or be in TV.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
I guess that's true.
AUDIENCE: Did these
guys back in the day
do this because they
wanted to do stand-up
or because they wanted to
be on a TV show, or both?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Well, it depends.
There was clear
differences between people.
There were people who came
out here, like Letterman,
for example.
Letterman wanted to be a
writer and a performer.
And he was born to do that.
And he did not come out
to be a stand-up comic.
But he looked around,
and he saw real quickly--
and this is in the book--
he says, well, I can
attract the attention
of people on the "The Tonight
Show" by going on that stage
and writing funny stuff.
And he was going to
write jokes and be
a writer, because he was a funny
weatherman back in Indiana.
And he was sort of
a local popular.
And there were other people,
like Michael Keaton, whose name
was Michael something else.
Michael Keaton, the
actor, came out,
and he changed his
name to Michael Keaton,
because there was somebody else.
And he was brilliant
at stand-up comedy.
He was really funny.
He had a really funny act.
But he really wanted
to be an actor.
And there was a lot more work,
and a lot more better paid
work if you could
be an actor, if you
could go become a comedian--
I mean, there's a difference.
The people at "Saturday Night
Live" were not stand-up comics.
There was a place on the
show for stand-up comics,
but stand-up's its own thing.
It's funny, but
it's its own thing.
It's not being a comedy actor.
That's a whole different game.
And it's a different
profession, in a way.
But you can make a lot more
money being in a sitcom.
And a lot of stand-ups
weren't good actors.
Jay Leno would probably-- he
wouldn't admit it back then,
but he eventually-- he
wasn't a good actor.
It's not what he was
comfortable doing.
He was naturally gifted
at being a comedian.
And believe me, when Jay
Leno was 27, 28 years old
and he was performing
on The Comedy Shop,
he was fall down
funny all the time.
And he could get up
there and talk and go off
the top of his head for hours.
He was amazing.
The guy you saw on "The Tonight
Show" all during those years,
he was doing that show
for them, for NBC.
But Leno on stage
in a comedy club
is a different thing altogether.
And he was really good at that.
And he wasn't a good actor.
And Letterman was great
at being a broadcaster,
and talking to people,
and being funny,
and he was great at that.
And a lot of them
became actors and they
became writers, and producers.
And they were in the
business of funny.
But they didn't go
on with the stand-up.
And a whole bunch of them
that you don't ever know,
after this strike was
over and they started
getting paid, went on the road
for the next five or six years
and made pretty good
money, traveling around
until they got
tired of doing that,
and doing one-nighters in
little water tank towns
around America, because comedy
was real simple and real
inexpensive to put on.
You needed a couple of chairs,
a couple of microphones.
That's all you needed.
You didn't need a sound
system of any particular.
You didn't need to pay the band.
You didn't need
to pay for music.
This was it.
So the comic walked away with
most of the performing money.
So they'd get paid pretty well.
And it's what they
were compelled to do.
And most of them-- and I
would say that all of them
were compelled to do it, meaning
there wasn't any way that you
could have stopped
them from doing it,
as hard as some people tried.
SCOT PANSING: Any
other questions?
I think we have time for
a couple more, if anyone--
anyone want to
catch the blue cube?
Here we go, up front.
Make it a good toss.
Nice.
AUDIENCE: So can you expand
more on "High Times?"
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
"High Times."
AUDIENCE: On the
title of the book.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Oh,
well, yeah, there was drugs.
Although this was-- again,
comedians at the time,
they weren't getting paid.
So there wasn't a lot of
coke that you can buy.
And this was sort of right
when coke was coming in.
And all of them
pretty much that--
if you hung out
around Mitzi, and you
were part of her
favorite, and you
were part of the crowd
around Richard Lewis,
you got free coke.
And that's in the book.
I don't want to go into it.
That's not a major story.
But I mean, you couldn't
stand outside the Comedy Store
for very long without
somebody handing you a joint.
But when coke came in, it
was kind of a separator.
And I was in Hollywood
and show business,
around it anyway,
back at the time.
And there was a changeover from
marijuana to coke back then.
I mean, marijuana, you
hand that around to people.
Nobody handed around coke,
because you couldn't afford it.
So if you wanted to do coke,
you went in the bathroom
with your best friend,
and everybody else
was kind of pissed.
There was no camaraderie
around doing cocaine.
So it wasn't a big thing with
the comics, because again,
most of them couldn't afford it.
SCOT PANSING: And it's
touched on in the show, too.
Pretty prevalent--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
And you know what?
All of Mitzi's-- this is not
me doing some sort of 12-step
thing, but most of them
who got involved with coke,
it didn't end well.
They all ended up in rehab.
It all derailed all their lives.
Richard Pryor ended up dead
and burned himself half to--
very short time after this,
you could see it coming.
So it didn't help anybody's
comedy, that's for sure.
Marijuana, I don't think
it had any effect one
way or the other.
But maybe it helped some.
SCOT PANSING: It helped
Rodney Dangerfield.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I had a
seat with Rodney Dangerfield.
I was sitting in
The Comedy Store
talking to Rodney
Dangerfield and Joey--
remember the guy from
"Car 54, Where Are You?"
Ooh, ooh.
That guy, he was an actor.
Anyway, but they were--
SCOT PANSING: I'm not that old.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I
was the LA Times reporter
and they handed me a joint.
And I had to go, thanks, but I--
and I handed it on.
Sort of a weird moment.
SCOT PANSING: With
those two guys?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Yeah, with
those two guys, in The Comedy
Store, with people
all around them.
So I had that happen a
lot of times, but later.
I never inhaled.
SCOT PANSING: Anyone else?
We have a few, or we
can call it a wrap.
Does anyone have another
question for the fuzzy cube?
AUDIENCE: I just
want to correct you.
It was Big Jay Oakerson, not
Jeff Ross, the show where--
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Oh,
I know who Jeff Ross is.
I don't know who
the other guy is.
SCOT PANSING: Big Jay Oakerson--
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to get his name out there.
SCOT PANSING: --was the show
where Tony Clifton performed.
AUDIENCE: It was the show
where Tony Clifton was on.
SCOT PANSING: Thank you.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
It's not Andy.
Just so you know.
Whoever it was, that's not Andy.
Andy is dead.
SCOT PANSING: We can't
reveal who he is?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: I'm not
saying he won't come back.
SCOT PANSING: I think you
can Google it and find out
who it is.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: Donald
Trump became president.
So Andy Kaufman could come back.
SCOT PANSING: Google it.
You can find out who it is.
I don't want to--
or find me after.
OK, yeah, leave the mystery.
Great.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Anybody else?
This is your last chance.
SCOT PANSING: Going
once, going twice.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Nobody wants
to know what my
favorite craft beer is?
No.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SCOT PANSING: Oh,
before we do-- stop it--
what is your next
project, your next book?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER: My
next project is a book.
It should be out
within the next year.
It's called "Fins" and it's
about the birth of the car
business as told through
the life of a guy named
Harley Earl, who invented
the profession of automobile
styling.
And he took General Motors
from being this little bitty
company to the most successful
corporation in the world,
because he figured out a way
for them to change their cars
every year, the look of them.
And he also was the guy who
put fins on cars in the 19502.
That's the--
SCOT PANSING: Nice.
When is that?
When do you expect that to be?
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
It's supposed
to come out in January of
2018, if I can finish it
in the next couple days.
All right, All right, well,
we'd better let you go, then.
Thanks for coming.
We'll let you go finish
your new latest book.
WILLIAM KNOEDELSEDER:
Thanks, guys.
Thank you, everybody.
SCOT PANSING: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]